[Musique]
beaucoup en font un chiffon rouge mais
qu'est-ce que le wokis mon ancien déjà
plus après ce documentaire exclusif
racisé une histoire
franco-américaine car c'est aux
États-Unis que cette approche sociétale
initialement centrée sur la question
raciale a trouvé ses racines et c'est sa
transposition ces dernières années nous
venons de le voir au sein de notre
modèle républicain qui provoque bien des
polémiques à juste titre et bien nous
allons en débattre maintenant avec nos
deux invités présents sur ce plateau à
commencer par celui qui a réalisé ce
film Michael phrasant bienvenue à vous
Michael présent vous êtes écrivain
documentariste avec déjà plus d'une
vingtaine de films à votre actif souvent
d'ailleurs engagé et à caractère
historique vous collaborez également au
magazine
francs-tireurs votre film est une libre
adaptation en tout cas comme cela que
vous le présentez de laisser intitulé
Racer réaliser et écrit par Rachel Kahn
que l'on voit dans ce film
c'est cela qui a déclenché votre
documentaire oui et non ça fait quand
même quelques années que je vois ce
phénomène venir à bas bruit d'abord en
France et puis prendre véritablement
dans certains milieux dans certaines
universités et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il a pris quand même une certaine
densité une certaine ampleur il prend
dans quel milieu il prend alors
déjà c'est compliqué de savoir de quel
million on parle est-ce que c'est des
milieux sociaux professionnels ou autre
on va dire pour résumer qu'il prend
beaucoup dans une certaine tranche d'âge
disons les moins de 25 ans via des
influenceurs ou des influenceuses sur
Internet et ça passe assez sous les
radars si vous voulez d'une autre
génération donc on ne le voit pas
forcément prendre ni venir il prend dans
certains milieux universitaires et
notamment les départements sociologiques
et puis il y a ce que j'essaye
brièvement vous expliquer dans le film
ce soft power américain via certaines
plateformes certaines séries qui donnent
à voir un certain mode de vie et c'est
là que que évidemment une influence
aussi
se rajoute à tout cela maintenant
pourquoi faire ce film je voulais pas
faire un pamphlet je vous laisse surtout
expliquer d'où ça vient parce que on
voit les choses et en même temps on sait
pas quel est leur origine et c'est ça
que j'avais raconté le cette histoire là
que j'avais envie de faire dans ce de
montrer dans ce documentaire bon on
comprend mieux vos motivations pour
réaliser ce film que nous venons de voir
d'où ça vient j'espère qu'on aura en
grande partie la réponse avec vous Anne
Lorraine Bujon bonjour vous êtes
directrice de la rédaction de la revue
Esprit chercheur associé également à
livrer l'Institut français des relations
internationales bien sûr on vous
intéressant tout particulièrement aux
questions d'histoire politique et
culturelle aux États-Unis les États-Unis
où vous avez d'ailleurs vécu durant de
très longues années wow Kiss ma j'ai
regardé le Bocuse ça veut dire ça veut
dire éveiller c'est le participe passé
de Wake qui veut dire éveillé un récent
sondage réalisé en septembre dernier
nous nous disait 86% des Français donc
sans doute une bonne partie de ceux qui
nous regardent aujourd'hui ne savent pas
ce qu'est le bokishme là il faut nous
expliquer après tous les éléments qui
ont bien sûr figurer dans ce film alors
je suis pas sûr que je vais complètement
vous aider parce que moi-même je ne suis
pas très sûr de savoir ce qu'est le
wokisme en tout cas je doute fort qu'il
s'agisse d'un mouvement ou d'une
idéologie concertée
unique bien cohérente voilà ce qui est
vrai c'est qu'il y a une nouvelle
sensibilité je dirais
à la question des discriminations dans
une génération donnée donc ça oui vous
l'avez dit je crois que cette question a
une forte dimension générationnelle on
est tous conscients comme ça je crois
que autour de nous des jeunes de 18-25
ans qui sont très préoccupés par
la question des discriminations raciales
mais aussi des discriminations sexuelles
et puis par dessus ça ils sont très
préoccupés par la question
environnementale qui n'a rien à voir
mais c'est vrai que dans cette classe
d'âge il y a cette sensibilité alors
vous avez rappelé l'étymologie donc le
l'adjectif walk il existe effectivement
et il sert un peu comme un signe de
reconnaissance entre différentes
personnes qui ont une très forte
conscience une conscience aiguisée de la
question raciale et de la question des
discriminations et qui prône une forme
d'éveil des consciences donc nous on a
la question raciale aux États-Unis c'est
d'ailleurs très bien expliqué dans ce
documentaire elle date pas d'hier compte
tenu les questions d'esclavage et de
ségrégation dans l'histoire politique
américaine et c'est impossible de
comprendre les débats actuels sans se
référer à cette histoire de l'esclavage
et de la ségrégation mais une des
difficultés que j'ai moi quand on met
face à face comme ça deux modèles ou
deux pays en les opposant à terme comme
si on pouvait opérer ce type de
réduction binaire c'est que on oublie
qu'il n'y a pas d'un côté les États-Unis
travaillé par la question raciale et de
l'autre côté la France qui elle aurait
une histoire absolument
idyllique avec pas de passer ni dans
l'esclavage ni dans la colonisation pas
de problème de représentation collective
ou de discrimination ou d'inégalité
liées aux origines si vous voulez c'est
un peu plus compliqué que ça et je crois
qu'on a intérêt dans ce genre de débat à
amener dans la pièce si on peut alors ça
fait déjà beaucoup de questions à
couvrir mais d'autres pays que les
États-Unis parce que si vous prenez un
des points de départ une des étincelles
très importantes pour cette nouveau ces
nouveaux mouvements antiracistes ça a
été le meurtre de George Floyd à aux
mains de la de la police de Minneapolis
mais ce meurtre de George Floyd et la
vague de manifestations black lives
matter qui ont suivi ça fait tâche
d'huile chez nous il y a eu des
manifestations très importantes
il y a eu des manifestations
ou alors
les villes noires comptent il y a deux
traductions possibles les vies noires
comptent avec ce slogan qu'on entend
scander au début du documentaire nojost
et snowpis sans justice nous n'aurons
pas de peine donc ça c'est des slogans
qui nous viennent tout droit du
mouvement des droits civiques américains
dans les années 60 donc il y a une
filiation et il y a une mutation de ces
mouvements antiracistes mais c'est très
important de voir que c'est pas les
États-Unis et la France et que cette
nouvelle sensibilité antiraciste les
vagues de déboulonnage de statut par
exemple c'est dans le monde entier donc
il faut s'interroger aussi sur un
mouvement historique là
c'est effectivement une histoire entre
la France et les États-Unis c'est
l'histoire d'un malentendu nous ne
sommes pas du tout sur le modèle
américain nos histoires ne sont pas
elles sont glorieuses moins glorieuses
là n'est pas la question je mets même en
doute si vous voulez cette définition
d'un antiracisme pour moi on est dans
autre chose
pas c'est pas ça qui réglera le racisme
je ne le crois pas et le problème si
vous voulez c'est que les États-Unis
sont complètement charpentés
fondées sur la question raciale au point
que le territoire est marqué par la
ségrégation par le racisme par
l'esclavage et ça fait vraiment partie
des névroses américaines moi je ne veux
pas juger les États-Unis se débrouillent
avec cet héritages comme il le peuvent
le problème si vous voulez c'est qu'il y
a quand même un messianisme américain
qui pense que ce qui vaut pour les
États-Unis vaut pour le reste du monde
or non nous n'avons pas la même histoire
même s'il y a des choses en commun mais
en tout cas notre modèle sociétal notre
modèle social notre idéal n'a rien à
voir alors le grand malentendu c'est
transposé un modèle
racialisé celui des États-Unis dans un
modèle dit universaliste et républicain
qui est le nôtre le grand malentendu
pour le vocabulaire nous prenons le
vocabulaire tel qu'il se fabrique aux
États-Unis et nous ne prenons même pas
la peine de l'adapter on le traduit
littéralement et devrait être valide en
tout point et en toute société qui
peuplent le monde non je ne le crois pas
du tout ne serait-ce que les mots qui
fabriquent cette identité ou ses
identités aux États-Unis le mot blanc le
mot noir moi je n'ai pas grandi avec ces
mots je n'ai pas grandi avec ces
oppositions et quand je vois aujourd'hui
ces jeunes gens qui sont des
influenceurs ou des influenceuses et qui
parlent et je le cite sur l'un des sites
que je montre dans le film de racisme de
d'universalisme de racistes et j'y vois
quand même comme une forme de paradoxe
et c'est à dire que ce qu'on nous
reproche aujourd'hui des gens de ma
génération par exemple qui ne prêtions
pas attention aux couleurs qui pensions
que la couleur était un élément de
l'identité mais qu'il ne devait pas
façonner une posture un mode de vie une
histoire nécessairement qui je dois le
dire à mon époque faisait partie de
l'intimité moi je ne demande pas aux
gens quel est votre origine s'ils
veulent me l'a donné il me l'a dit on
peut en discuter c'est un élément parmi
d'autres et si vous voulez il y a tout
un phénomène d'inversion dans le Woking
ou ce que nous croyons étant juste
devient le pire devient une forme de
fascisme ne pas voir les couleurs
aujourd'hui des gens c'est être
colorblind c'est être au fond le
dépositaire d'une forme de racisme moi
je m'assure je contre ça je crois que
notre modèle est le bon je crois que
c'est le seul possible pour vivre
ensemble or des névroses et des
traumatismes américains communautariste
et je crois que c'est voilà c'est c'est
ça que nous devons garder c'est le cap
que nous devons suivre et je trouve que
toutes ces invasions du vocabulaire et
des idées faussement politique qui sont
d'ailleurs pour certaines intéressantes
d'autres totalement fausses
ineptes inapte ou si logistes voilà je
pense qu'il faut aujourd'hui reparler de
tout ça poser le débat et si possible
rectifier le tir
alors là on vient d'entendre un tenant
de la parole universaliste française
ces arguments là on les entend aussi aux
États-Unis dans une société c'est vrai
communautariste
oui ils ont eu lieu mais ils ont lieu
dans les Antilles et les Antilles ont
une histoire et une géographie
particulière qui en
Anglet nos Pays-Bas et ce que je veux
dire c'est que
des verrouillés
du modèle républicain et du modèle
universaliste et alors déjà il faudrait
ici faire des nuances moi aussi je suis
universaliste comment ne pas l'être
évidemment c'est un idéal évidemment on
y inspire tous mais il faut aussi
reconnaître quand il y a des failles
dans cette idéale quand il fonctionne
pas quand la République n'est pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'elle promet et je crois
que dans cette jeunesse antiraciste il y
a ce besoin de dire ça alors une chose
que j'ai beaucoup aimé dans le
documentaire c'est qui termine sur la
figure de James boldwin qui je crois est
une figure absolument centrale pour
comprendre cette histoire aux États-Unis
mais aussi la circulation avec la France
puisque vous rappelez que boldwin a vécu
en France où il était très heureux etc
donc il fait partie de cette génération
de noir américain qui ont participé qui
ont accompagné le mouvement des droits
civiques et si vous voulez boldwin pour
moi c'est la même qu'on peut raconter
une histoire
éminemment située on dirait dans le
vocabulaire des sciences sociales
aujourd'hui éminemment particulière et
spécifique il était noir de ces familles
noires qui ont fui le sud pour remonter
dans le Nord il était homosexuel donc il
était doublement victime de
discrimination et très malheureux à ce
titre dans la société américaine de
l'après-guerre mais boldwin il vous
raconte une histoire très spécifique
très particulière très situés dans
laquelle il touche à l'universel et
pourquoi il touche à l'universel parce
qu'il vous raconte des histoires
d'injustice et d'oppression et qu'on
peut tous s'identifier à une histoire de
justice et d'oppression pareil pour un
Aimé Césaire chez nous est-ce qu'aimer
ses airs n'étaient pas universaliste
quand il proclamait je suis [__] à un
moment il faut reconnaître qui peut y
avoir des spécificités d'une expérience
d'une condition noire au 20e siècle en
Afrique aux États-Unis en France
aujourd'hui qui demande à être se rend
compte pour réparer des injustices chez
nous quand il y a des manifs monstres
après le meurtre de George Floyd c'est
pas parce que toute la jeunesse
française est manipulée par la Maison
Blanche c'est parce qu'il y a une
persistance de représentation
collective sur ce qu'est un noir sur ce
qu'est un arabe d'inégalité
socio-économique réel et de
discrimination réelle
il reste du racisme dans la société
française pour autant je ne valide pas
le racisme systémique ou le racisme
d'État c'est tout le contraire voilà si
vous voulez c'est pas parce qu'il y a
des éléments de réalité universelle si
on veut que ces éléments doivent être
pris comme argent comptant par ailleurs
les situations américaines je suis
désolé il n'y a pas eu de manifestation
monstres en France après l'assassinat de
Georges Floyd il y a eu des
manifestations qui se sont voulus le
pendant de qui a eu aux Etats-Unis avec
Black lives matter et après l'assassinat
George Floyd sur la question de ce jeune
homme Adama Traoré et on a voulu
identifier ou faire un copier-coller
exact de la situation américaine à la
situation française je ne crois pas que
ce soit le cas donc voilà jusqu'à 2020
et ça c'est important de le souligner il
y a une forme de mimétisme qui me semble
préjudiciable pour nous et je pense que
les États-Unis ont leur propre si vous
voulez réalité sociale
raciale historique qui explique ce qui
se passe chez eux mais la volonté de
l'exporter chez nous pourquoi pas si
vous voulez mais je pense que nous
sommes à côté de la plaque en prenant
encore une fois pour argent comptant ces
modalités là qui à mon avis ne sont non
seulement pas les nôtres mais ne sont
pas les bonnes alors pour les tenants de
cette idéologie je sais que vous n'aimez
pas trop ce terme je vais tout de même
l'employer il s'agit maintenant de
déconstruire
faut déconstruire le suprammatisme blanc
le patriarcat il s'agit maintenant de
déconstruire d'où le déboulonnage et ce
qu'on appelle la cancells culture
c'est-à-dire de cette capacité à effacer
les choses vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
moi donc je vous efface c'est ça le
principe
le décontrustivisme
encore un terme en Nice
est-ce que ce n'est pas là qu'il y a
aussi une à malentendu entre les
Etats-Unis et la France parce que ça
c'est une notion qui avait été mise en
avant par un certain nombre de nos
philosophes dans les années 60-70
Deleuze Bourdieu ils sont tous cités
d'ailleurs dans ce documenté c'est un
des autres points de passage qui est mis
en lumière dans le documentaire là où on
va tomber d'accord quand même c'est que
effectivement les deux sociétés ne sont
pas les mêmes mais il y a des
circulations il y a des passages il y a
des emprunts il y a des choses qui
voyagent voilà alors Michel Foucault des
Rida et autres ils ont voyagé aux
États-Unis et c'est en fait aux
États-Unis qu'ils ont été reconnus
d'abord et puis après ça s'est appelé le
donc la french théorie mais c'est vrai
que les universités américaines en ont
fait un usage contre lesquels nous on se
révolte un peu on n'est pas complètement
à l'aise avec cette façon que que qu'on
a eu aux États-Unis d'utiliser Michel
Foucault pour pour durcir une politique
des du des identité dans laquelle si
vous voulez tout est pouvoir tout est
dominations il y aurait forcément
mais ça c'est des lectures de Bourdieu
et de Foucault qui sont un peu des
lectures c'est un peu vite vu et c'est
un peu simplificateur et donc là aussi
on va tomber d'accord sur le fait que
dans la façon dont certains de ces mots
d'ordre sont repris par des mouvements
de jeunesse et des influenceurs sur les
réseaux et autres il y a beaucoup de
simplification il y a du sectarisme il y
a de l'intolérance il y a de la bêtise
parfois tout simplement enfin des choses
mal comprises mal lu et donc moi je ne
suis pas du tout pour une vision de la
société où il y aurait un bloc de dominé
un bloc de dominants et on serait
toujours en train
opprimé ou oppresseurs je crois que la
société c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça les relations humaines y compris
les relations de pouvoir c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que ça et donc c'est
important de mettre de la triangulation
et de sortir de ses oppositions binaires
si vous voulez on n'est pas ou
universaliste
ou persuadé qu'il y a un problème de
discrimination et qu'il faut lutter
contre dans mon cas on est les deux je
pense qu'il y a un vrai problème de
discrimination dans nos sociétés
démocratiques modernes je suis pas très
étonnée qu'on aille chercher des
références aux États-Unis si vous voulez
le mouvement des droits civiques c'est
des héros enfin pourquoi on se
référerait pas à Martin Luther King ou à
Rosas comme on se réfère à Gandhi
jusqu'à la fin des années 60 c'est très
récent c'est voilà je suis désolé mais
voilà alors évidemment il y a des
histoires en commun il y a des éléments
qui sont communs l'esclavage la
colonisation etc mais enfin il y a pas
eu de ségrégation jusqu'à la fin des
années 60 sur le territoire français ça
change quand même beaucoup de choses
de ségrégation elle a eu lieu avant
durant la colonisation orchestrée pour
grande partie par la Troisième
République il y a des formes
qui intervient dans le débat français
je rappelle qu'elle a fait qu'au milieu
du 19e siècle en France les noirs et
surtout les métisses même si c'était pas
le cas complètement
interdit sur le territoire français
parce que c'était la mauvaise conscience
de cette France esclavagiste il y avait
tout un tas de raisons je ne nie pas
l'histoire ce que je dis si vous voulez
c'est la volonté de la contrefaire c'est
la volonté de l'effacer c'est la volonté
de la rectifier non en réalité ce qu'il
faut faire c'est plus d'histoire c'est
enseigner l'histoire c'est la donnée à
comprendre c'est éviter l'anachronisme
et le bouquinisme c'est tout le
contraire de ça alors vous dites vous
plaît pas changeons là vous dites dans
votre film le Bocuse prolifère parce que
et à cause des limites des carences de
notes modèle républicain et notamment de
la méritocratie cette valeur même
c'est ça que vous dites aujourd'hui donc
cette théorie toujours comme théorie une
idéologie prolifère auprès des jeunes
générations aujourd'hui parce que ces
jeunes n'auraient pas le sentiment on
peut toujours faire mieux l'ascenseur
sociale marche toujours en France dans
notre modèle je suis pas complètement
d'accord avec eux
la question idéologique c'est une
idéologie qui a ses propres mécanismes
ses propres sophisme ou Herman et qui a
ses propres pulsions il y a une pulsion
totalitaire dans le banquise mais il y a
une pulsion épuratrice dans le walkisme
mais d'ailleurs je voulais la rapprocher
voir une culture antisémite c'est ce
qu'on a cru comprendre sinon on dit
voilà c'est une possibilité et
d'ailleurs il y a un certain nombre et
je le dis très brièvement j'aurais voulu
m'étendre davantage sur la question
notamment des asiatiques et très
intéressantes qui eux aussi ont connu le
colonialisme qui ont connu les
dévastations de la guerre de la
suggestions des dominants maintenant en
tout cas ils sont absents du discours
wow ça c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'une
contre-culture parce que la construction
américaine lorsqu'elle a franchi
l'Atlantique elle a elle a elle a
provoqué des avancées aussi du côté du
Vieux Continent dans les années 50 dans
les années 60-70 bien sûr on peut parler
d'une contre-culture lorsqu'on parle du
wokis alors quand c'est très bien
si vous voulez avec des films des livres
qui deviennent des références oui comme
ont été une visible man de Ralph Elison
ou black boy de Richard Wright oui là ça
devient une contre-culture et elle peut
nourrir une culture chez nous nous aussi
on a une contre-culture dans les dans
les cités avec des cultures urbaines qui
véhiculent leurs propres représentation
dont certaines sont empruntées aux
États-Unis mais d'autres tout à fait
ailleurs là si vous voulez je crois
qu'on parle aussi d'une vulgarisation et
d'une simplification d'une banalisation
de certains de ces mots d'ordre sur les
réseaux sociaux qui prêtent à toutes les
simplifications et à des mots d'ordre
qui sont parfois désastreux donc si vous
voulez lire aujourd'hui toutes les
revendications
identitaires du côté féministe du côté
LGBT plus cette vision que la société
serait toujours divisée en deux groupes
comme je disais dominant dominé opprimé
oppresseurs vous pouvez l'appliquer sur
un certain nombre de questions
sur toutes ces questions mais je veux
lire le débat est suffisamment confus
pour qu'on essaye de ne pas tout
mélanger là je crois que le documentaire
porte sur la question raciale et c'est
très bien comme ça parce qu'on voit que
il y a déjà fort à faire c'est quand
même compliqué donc et les réseaux
sociaux n'aident pas du tout ça ça c'est
évident est-ce que le vaucus m'a fait
avancer la cause féministe la cause de
certaines
communautés minoritaires en France
c'est la cause LGBT par exemple c'est
une question de curseur c'est un peu
comme le mouvement me too bien sûr qu'il
y a des choses à prendre il y a des
choses à réfléchir des États-Unis aussi
penser bien sûr en France ça devient
balance son port mais
simultanément quand même oui alors
évidemment on est tous eu dans un
railiement du langage en France qui est
un petit peu plus voilà la question
est-ce que ça fait avancer les choses
dans un certain nombre de domaines
notamment le féminisme
c'est une question de curseur c'est à
dire que effectivement lorsqu'on a des
lanceurs d'alerte et on pourrait
finalement les présenter comme tel si ça
se si ça se réduit à ça c'est positif le
problème c'est quand ça devient un
dogmatiquement ça devient ce dont on
discutait tout à l'heure une idéologie
là ça me semble problématique et
effectivement on est dans une recherche
avec le wookisme de binarité
oui il y a un malentendu avec la french
théorie mais en même temps il y a un
certain nombre de marqueurs alors
effectivement des Rida c'est la
déconstruction il parlait de la
linguistique ça n'a rien à voir et
ensuite il y a la question du pouvoir et
Foucault et ensuite avec Bourdieu il y a
cette question de la binarité le dominer
le dominant et à partir du moment où on
arrive à cette grille de lecture
extrêmement réductrice qui enlève à
l'humanité au fond toute sa complexité
toute sa nuance on en vient à une
situation de guerre c'est la guerre de
tout ce contre tous alors je vois que
vous avez pas tout à fait et c'est la
fin de cette émission est-ce que ça a
fait avancer un certain nombre de causes
aurait pu mais il y a quoi de
heureusement le curseur a été déplacé
trop loin et ça devient totalement
contre-productif bon si j'ai bien
répondu à votre question et ben ça sera
le mot de la fin vraiment un grand merci
à tous les deux d'avoir participé à ce
débat doc aujourd'hui autour bien
entendu de votre
documentaire Michael présent être nuancé
et avant tout essayé de comprendre le
phénomène de montrer d'où ça vient et
d'avoir pour interlocuteur qui porte
cette parole wok quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup qui est cette américaine iaure
où il y aams et qui est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement intelligent éloquent et je
préférais avoir à faire sa liste voilà
comme lui qui nous explique ce phénomène
ancré dans les États-Unis ancré dans son
pays qu'avoir des ersatz de ce discours
ici bon en tout cas j'espère qu'on aura
déclaré la grande majorité des Français
qui ne savent pas aujourd'hui ce dont on
parle lorsqu'il est question de walk it
c'était aussi la vocation de votre film
et de cet échange que nous avons eu sur
ce plateau de débat doc vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter
alors là j'imagine qu'elles seront
nombreuses et je compte d'ailleurs sur
chacun d'entre vous deux pour réagir à
ce que sont ces réactions c'est le
Massaly m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission comme à l'accoutumée je le
remercie prochain rendez-vous avec des
badox ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]